[Musik]
eine zensur findet nicht statt
so steht es in artikel 5 des
grundgesetzes dieser satz soll eine
freie presse und freie meinungsäußerung
garantieren
denn journalisten können in deutschland
berichten ohne dass der staat eingreift
zensur bedeutet hingegen kontrolle
dabei entscheidet der staat was
veröffentlicht wird er überprüft die
meinungen in der zeitung die nachricht
im fernsehen oder den witz im internet
was dem staat nicht passt zensiert er
zensur ist vor allem in autoritären
ländern verbreitet durch die kontrolle
will die regierung ihre macht sichern
so kann sich die bevölkerung nicht über
missstände und andere meinungen
informieren
staatliche kontrolle ist nicht das
einzige mitteln denn in manchen ländern
zensieren sich beispielsweise
journalisten selbst dass sie sich vor
gewalt oder strafen fürchten sehen sie
von kritischen veröffentlichungen ab
deutschland steht im internationalen
vergleich gut da in der rangliste der
pressefreiheit von reporter ohne grenzen
liegt die bundesrepublik auf platz 11
von 180 doch auch ohne staatliche zensur
gibt es hier schranken
das grundrecht auf pressefreiheit hat da
seine grenze wo gesetze verletzt werden
etwa durch beleidigungen oder den
eingriff in persönlichkeitsrechte dann
entscheidend gerichte handelt es sich um
zulässige kritik oder um üble nachrede
der begriff zensur wandelt sich
ursprünglich bedeutete er in erster
linie die zensur durch den staat
doch auch social media plattformen wie
facebook oder tik tok geratenen verdacht
ihre algorithmen sollen manche inhalte
benachteiligen sagen kritiker da diese
plattform in der kommunikation und der
recherche nach informationen immer
wichtiger werden stellt sich die frage
was bedeutet es wenn nicht der staat
sondern große unternehmen gewisse
meinungen und informationen
kontrollieren was denkt ihr